[Music]
it's been like this for hours
hey swanson
snap out of it
leslie
congratulate us
ron's got one just like it on his penis
oh yeah
what the hell happened to you
well
[Music]
you may now kiss the bride
[Music]
it's been kind of a crazy night come
back
hello ron
it's ron
if you're watching this it means that
once again you have danced with the
devil right now you're probably thinking
tammy's changed we'll be happy together
but you're only thinking that because
she's a monstrous parasite
who entered through your privates and
lodged herself in your brain
so you have two choices one
get rid of tammy or two lobotomy and
castration
choose wisely stupid
this is a waste of time
you people have no idea what you're
talking about that was you
on the tape that was you talking ron
ron
there you are
uh
ron
stop it god please ron don't do that oh
it's done leslie
tammy and i are in love and we're gonna
start a family together
in fact she's ovulating so if you'll
excuse us
we're heading off on our honeymoon wow
where are you going jerry we're going to
spend 11 days in my cabin in the woods
we bought 10 cases of gatorade and a
40-pound bag of peanuts for energy oh
god give me it
okay excuse me
yeah oh god
uh hi pam halpert yes hi uh i'm clark uh
josie said you might benefit from a
lactation consultant
um yeah yeah that would be great really
great okay when she available actually
uh i'm the consultant
got milk
all right
let's see what we're working with
so uh the biggest thing besides not
being able to get her to laugh i'll ship
it for you oh thank you is that um i i
can't tell if i'm really producing i i
don't know if she's getting anything let
me feel here okay yeah it's quite full
but once you put your hand on top of my
hand okay when you're feeding you want
to
press in like this make your hand in a c
uh does that hurt
no i mean it feels
pressure okay sure it doesn't hurt no
okay it just feels like pressure yeah
i'm flicking the nipple
like that yeah you could stimulate it
all right so you just want to do that
and that will uh perfect and you can
just the baby should grab on to that i
think you will so i'm just not sure if
i'm releasing though i'm not sure if
you'll figure it out it doesn't probably
why don't you bring your baby over here
okay
she's beautiful oh thank you
congratulations thank you
well you're doing a good job just stay
relaxed and
i'll come back in a bit to check on you
okay okay please do
i don't know about this
well i'm offering you a free scan
usually costs up to two thousand dollars
kind of spoiling you here
well
i am a little curious good
and frankly i don't want to invest in
someone who only has three months to
live
oh i'm just trying to think of this as
an adventure you know
just
getting right back on that horse
even if that horse is crazy and wants to
peer inside my body
how does that feel
uh weird perfect
oh you're not on your period are you
no does that matter well not for this
okay it's gonna be a little crammed in
there don't worry i'll be right on the
other side of that glass
just your basic assistant stuff taking
messages wake up calls muscle milk runs
condom runs bottle service of the
snakehole lounge that kind of stuff
sorry what do i get out of this
connections plus 19 grand a year minus
my 10 head honors fee
i have to pay you two grand if i get
hired i have a job to offer in the
immortal words of rod blaglowicz
valuable thing you just don't give it
away for nothing
so you never told me where you're from
i'm from pawnee keep still please
what kind of music do you like
can i answer that sure keep still
all kinds
very important that you keep still at
this moment leslie
i've told you that a thousand times
do you ever break your arm
you can answer that here i'll turn it
off
one time i was on my bike and some boys
were making fun of me so i chased them
and i lost control
i'm surprised you can see that
it was like three years ago
i can't believe i turned the machine off
for that
you never had any kids right leslie
hello
you've got a great oven okay
time to go we got ample room in there
honestly if you wanted to
you could go triplets right off the bat
leslie you got a big
industrial sized oven so we're done
right
[Music]
hi i'm just gonna just for just a sec
um everyone i'm sorry should i have your
attention please
thank you
ah
hi sorry i just have an announcement to
make
um
okay
i have learned a lot
about indian culture tonight
but i have learned even more about love
and i know you're all thinking who is
this crazy gringo and what is he talking
about
well i'm not crazy
maybe i'm crazy in love
so without further ado
carol
carol stills
i would like you
to do me the honor
of making me
your husband
oh michael
what are you saying
can we talk about this in private
i didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
[Music]
so
how are you awesome i am dating a lot of
guys good a lot black guys mostly
kelly what
wait uh
how do you touch just one of these
buttons at a time
i don't know
did you even try
if the kid wants to set mine up i'll let
him i can't see half the things it's too
little use the phone
i want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what i want kelly i'm
your boss now okay you can't keep
talking to me like i'm your boyfriend oh
big strong man fancy new whatever i
don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you six months ago
karen filippelli sent me an email asked
me out i said no because i was committed
to our relationship well i hope you're
still committed because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner we'll
talk about it then okay
we have a date
you